you know one of the main reasons I
really enjoyed coming down to comic-con
in San Diego is just the great people
that turnout I mean so many people from
all over and I'm although I'm sorry but
someone in the audience this is rude
seems to be dozing off excuse me excuse
me wake up sir wake up wake up okay
thank you thank you very much by the way
what character are you supposed to be oh
I am outstanding woke outstanding bulk
don't you mean the incredible no lawyer
advised me to go by name outstanding
book vote don't want get sued okay well
I I believe even the outstanding bulk
could stay awake during my show you
should give it a try
okay just stay awake sorry well tired
and not on top of game not feeling like
true self you know what this seems like
a perfect opportunity for some product
placement you're right Andy let's get
this boat guy a snicker
well there you go
you're feeling better there
yeah well bulkier and wide-awake both
mash whoa no bulk I think you mean smash
no I said both mash you know again bull
not want to be sued oh yeah gotcha all
right thanks Snickers
[Applause]
you